options of that bar and restaurant Vibe
right here in Vegas STK is one of the
best options yeah okay very excited very
excited now um
you know you can have a you can have
some football with the side of steak I
feel like that's absolutely that's
pretty on brand for the Super Bowl
absolutely it's on Brandon what else
what else do you want besides a ton of
steak sliders hamburgers everything that
SDK does you guys know if you're looking
for a place to come for the Super Bowl
we are your spot so but normally SDK is
a little Chic and sexy but this time
we're going all sporty so talk about the
energy the vibe what people are going to
walk into well if you know SDK what
you're walking into is an SDK experience
it is Chic it is sexy it's loud it's fun
and we're throwing in the Super Bowl on
top of it we got high definition
monitors all over the restaurant okay no
matter where you sit you're going to be
able to have a clear view of the game
and we're going to have a plethora of
food some Fanfare or traditional menus
and we have seasonal menus that we're
going to have there for everybody to
enjoy okay Chef you said lots of food
you said a plethora I love that one now
let's talk about this plethora right
here absolutely this is crazy I just
want to pick this up no that's why
that's one of our Australian wagyu
tomahawks we have right here uh
definitely a uh favorite there you know
our Fanfare that we're you're going to
be seeing uh some of the things that are
Super Bowl you're going to have our
absolutely truffle popcorn who doesn't
love truffle popcorn I don't know if you
don't um you're questionable I love it
we have a five why you tacos and we're
gonna have A5 nachos we have chicken
wings our sliders will have a variety of
hamburgers there always our SDK fries
big time favorite of course and
everything else okay let's talk about
the steak please let's talk about this
steak the lobster a little surf and turf
Vibe we got vegetables that's it a
little bone marrow bone marrow yeah
roasted bone marrow these are platters
that you can come in and we have we'll
have them put together for you
definitely made for the shared
experience that's one thing that SDK is
great for you come in with your party
and then we set up a table that you can
share and have a bunch of food and just
sit back relax watch the game have fun
you know and uh for everything even
Valentine's Day true true I know you're
coming through on Valentine's Day it's
two days away so if you missed the Super
Bowl oh I want to see you there on
Valentine's Day I love it I love it now
um you know you also have to go with
this plethora of food bottomless
beverages you have to we have everybody
about what we're drinking we do we have
we have a beverage package that has all
sorts of you know everything uh
from all the booze but Makers Mark
McCarty you know all the things we're
sponsored we're sponsored by Budweiser
so you're going to see plenty of that
there and then you know we have all our
food all the cart that you'll just be
able to enjoy wow I love it are you
gonna be there I am going to absolutely
I'm gonna be there I wouldn't miss it
for the world I love it so how can
people make a reservation really quick
they can make a reservation by uh
calling us at
702-698-7990 uh getting a hold of us
there and uh we'll take it from there
you got the phone number from the
executive chef of SDK okay make sure you
call and make your preservation it's a
great place to mix and drop it in that's
a that's a good way to do it okay I I
saw Chef Tim speaking of dropping news
mix and mingle at STK yeah you might
meet your Valentine you know what I'm
saying all right up next on Las Vegas